-My next guest
is a very funny comedian
and "New York Times"
best-selling author.
She has a new show called "Doing
the Most with Phoebe Robinson,"
which airs Fridays at 11:00 p.m.
on Comedy Central.
Please welcome Phoebe Robinson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
Come on now.
Welcome. Welcome.
Thank you for coming back
to our show, pal.
I appreciate it.
-Thanks for having me.
-Phoebe, this is your third time
on our show since the pandemic.
We've seen each other
through different stages
of the quarantine.
How are you right now?
How are you feeling?
-I'm over it, Jimmy.
I want to get out, okay?
-I know. Okay. Yes.
-I want to go to a concert.
-Okay.
-Smell some B.O.
I don't care who's playing.
Okay, it can Chumbawamba.
I want to be out
in these streets.
I'm done.
-You're done.
Okay, I got you.
Okay, I hear you.
I saw you posted this photo
that made me laugh.
You said, "I just want everyone
to know that this is what
I'm wearing when it's time
to get my vaccine."
-Yeah. Mm-hmm.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Ooh, la, la!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at those tiny boobies
just out and proud.
[ Laughter ]
Love it.
-Phoebe, I heard that you got
your first shot this weekend.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Is this what you
ended up wearing?
-No. Jimmy, you know me
well enough to know
I did not bring it.
I was looking like
a hot-ass mess.
I was in drawstring jeans
and mom sneakers.
I didn't have a wig on.
It was a hot mess.
Yeah. Yeah.
-Buddy, you're doing
so many cool things.
I want to make sure I hit
all the bases here.
This first thing I want to
talk to you about is
that you have another book
coming out this fall,
and you posted the cover here.
Yeah, it says,
"Please Don't Sit On My Bed
In Your Outside Clothes."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes. Yes.
-This is your third book here.
Has the process gotten
any easier?
-It has.
I feel like when I wrote
my first book, I was --
Every day I was like
Claire Danes in "Homeland."
I was just crying.
It was ugly.
It was not cute.
But this time it was good.
It was really good,
and the title is
a public-service announcement
to white people
to not sit on my bed
after you've been on a subway.
-Someone is passing out
in our audience right now.
[ Laughter ]
I've never heard this sound,
but when you said "wh-white,"
someone almost --
-"Wh-White."
-"Wh-White," yes.
[ Laughter ]
It's great to hear that laugh.
Gosh, I've missed the laughs.
Speaking of the laughs,
you're about to hit
a stand-up milestone.
You're getting your own special
on HBO.
Phoebe Robinson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-That's a huge deal, bud!
Phoebe.
-Thank you.
Thank you. I'm so excited.
I'm so pumped up.
I've been doing stand-up
for 13 years.
And I'm glad that I'm finally
reaching this milestone.
I'm pinching myself every day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good for you bud.
Good for you. I love 'em!
So excited for you.
I want to talk about
your new show.
This is "Doing the Most
with Phoebe Robinson"
on Comedy Central.
You interview celebrities
while also learning a new skill.
-Yeah, so, basically I came up
with the show
because I'm a type-A workaholic
and I have, like, no skills.
I can't drive. I can't cook.
I can't start a fire.
Like, if this was like the movie
"A Quiet Place,"
I would just make a bunch of
noise so I could get killed
so everyone else can survive.
[ Laughter ]
And so with this show,
I just kind of wanted to learn
how to do different things,
like baking, some sort of
more physical stuff --
riding a horse with
Whitney Cummings.
And it's been a lot of fun.
I'm definitely learning
a lot of new skills.
-We do that on our show, too.
We play games with celebrities
just so you see
a different side.
And you do get in there.
I actually like --
You do a thing called
"Three Big Questions"
or three --
-Yes.
-BQs.
-Three BQs. Mm-hmm.
-There's something interesting
about this interview style
that we've not tried
on the show,
but you --
you spoon with your guests.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, you know what?
Yes, you have to, sometimes
as an excuse, to just sort of
be close with a hot gentleman
that I would have no chance with
in real life.
[ Laughter ]
But in all seriousness,
it's just really great.
When you're, like, being held,
like, you let your guard down,
and sometimes you'll be funny
and sometimes
you'll be vulnerable.
-What are you talking about?
-I think next time --
-No, no, no.
I can't spoon people
when they come on the show.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-Yes. Yes, you can.
-I cannot.
-You can spoon Michelle Obama.
-No, I cannot spoon
Michelle Obama on the show!
Absolutely not! You can.
-Yes, you can.
-No. You can.
I do want to show a clip.
Here's Phoebe Robinson
and Kevin Bacon
in this week's "Doing the Most
with Phoebe Robinson."
Take a look at this.
-Okay, so what do I do next?
-So maybe just
a little sidestep,
you know, kind of shimmy,
start moving.
-But then what do I grab on to?
I'm just holding the rope?
-Yeah. Just hold on to the rope.
And hold on tight --
-No, not the hoop.
-One of my hoops just fell,
Kevin!
-Oh, no.
'Cause we got to start again.
-I just want to make a deal
that if I fall off this,
I'm not getting back on,
and it's fine
because, you know,
it's my civil rights.
Martin Luther King Jr. fought
so I could say no
to white nonsense
whenever I want.
[ Laughter ]
-Unbelievable.
You are unbelievable!
I love you. Phoebe Robinson!
"Doing the Most with
Phoebe Robinson" airs Fridays
at 11:00 p.m. on Comedy Central.